mass murder in Broward County was a huge
story but what about another chilling
event where nothing nearly as bad
happened but could have st. George Utah
homemade explosive was found in a
backpack on Monday students saw the
backpack in a common area at Pine View
High which looked to be smoking but
police said the student who notified
faculty and a school officer prevented
an explosion that would have caused mass
casualties police got to the suspects
home found the bomb-making materials as
well as info suggesting he'd been
researching Isis now last month the
suspect may have also replaced the
American flag at a different high school
with an Isis one and painted part of an
Isis inspired threat on one school wall
so why don't you hear about this story
well it's obvious first the bomb didn't
go off that's how news works we never
report when a plane lands safely and of
course the weapon was not a gun but a
bomb anyway we should be grateful that
no one got hurt but don't be relieved
because the only reason why no one got
hurt is that they got lucky that
backpack smoked and a kids saw it so I
returned to the solutions hardening soft
targets surveillance cameras should have
caught the kid painting the walls or
replacing the flag and metal detectors
could do a lot to reduce all threats but
right now all we have to rely on our
eyeballs and chance we can do better
[Music]